So Aaron asked the question again, real quick, by the way, hold on who I heard you say somebody's
new who you mentioned that was new Daniel true Daniel welcome to the call.
You're in for a treat and I know Aaron real quick we can make a plug.
We are like, we have committed to quadrupling down on the value and I've said this for about
a month, maybe a little bit longer but yeah there's going to be a lot of.
For those of you that have been around a while, you guys are going to see a huge uptick in.
I don't know if I'd say service or just raw value that we're going to be giving you guys
and so we're talking about this almost every day so anyway, Daniel welcome to call anyone
else that's brand new on this I'm going to try to pull Facebook here I'm going to log
in while Francesca answer this question but welcome to this call.
The purpose is with this is to give you guys, you know, everything that we you need to know
is in the training you could go through the training that could be training.
You don't need me, you could be training plus the community, you have every answer to every
question you could possibly have, however, we try to come on here to give you just that
extra training the the the new updates the this the that the specific nuance questions
because we can never, it'd be impossible to answer every single question but here's the
great part is if you guys ask these questions on these calls, like Aaron's about to ask
Francesca, we're going to cut that a little assuming the answer doesn't suck, Francesca
we're going to cut it.
Just kidding.
And then we're going to put that inside of the Kajabi training so that we can have the
specific questions the nuanced questions as many as possible inside the training.
So if you guys have been in this group, the training changes every single week we literally
have add we add one to three to five new videos every single week I don't know if you guys
continually logging in but we want you guys in there and checking it out.
So that said, go ahead and ask the question let's get into it.
Yeah, absolutely.
So Daniel says, how do you vet these videos instead of just picking the first one?
Yeah, so I think it starts when you're transferring the free leads to them and your live transferring
yourself like that's the first thing that you want to watch out is to the sound professional,
you know, that's the first thing that you really notice and usually that gives you a
pretty good idea.
And then the second one is when you get on a zoom call, also like the follow up like
when you follow up on those leads that you sent over how quicker they do answer the closing
them if not do they have stupid excuses.
So that's another thing.
And then another one would be when you get on a zoom call before you kind of start you
ask them questions like are you looking to grow where are you at gather as much as information
before you even start going into you know wasting too much time and that would probably
be the final thing you do to check it.
You kind of get a pretty good idea after you do all of that to be honest especially after
you close a bunch of them because you get the senses that kind of tell you this is good
this is not good.
Yeah, do you have a couple like specifics real quick on this question like and that
opening cold call obviously this is a little hard because it's a balance if you don't want
to get hung up on but then also you don't want to agree to give them free leads if they're
not a good fit like what are some telltale signs you look on and that first cold call
of like if they're maybe a good fit or not.
Yeah, I think like breaking that relationship during the cold calling is way easier than
waiting to do the zoom call anyway.
So you if you catch something off I would almost suggest being stricter then because
that way you're not wasting too much time you know because there's always going to be
not always but you're going to have a few more free leads to send someone else at that
point.
I would say like if you transfer I had one I remember I transferred the lead and he
wouldn't talk so I said hello are you there and we're like all he would say was yeah
like introduce yourself like say something and that to me was like okay no like he wouldn't
say you know anything his name nothing even you know you introduce them but still like
you've got to have someone that sounds alive on the other end so stuff like that like you
just kind of feel off I would say that sounds unprofessional or I've had a few like you
transfer the lead they sound good and then when you check in on them and say hey how
did that go did you close them did you give them a quote and they get back to you saying
um I didn't have enough time I have to call them back then you're like okay stuff like
that will make you kind of wonder you'll know yeah for sure and like actually like I added
one quick thing like they got to want leads if they're a cavalier about it you don't really have
that much control if they're like and we're doing pretty good like they could be lying so it could
be a smoke screen so you don't want to address that but like I remember talking with one dude
he was like 55 I don't know what I was thinking homeboy was not ready to hustle for more leads
right and so I didn't really have like any leverage or any control because he didn't care
and so in that situation you like the guys that are hungry to grow again just because someone
says we're doing good doesn't mean they actually aren't hungry and they could get really hooked
by your free leads but that's still something to focus on and you can do the pull back then
like if they act like that and they're like well I'm already and then be like then what did you
agree on getting a few free jobs if you're already great right do you want them or do you not then
you're like you can just be honest with me you know you know I'm a big man you can just tell me
and then they're usually like no that's not what I meant or whatever something done like that
that's usually what they say looks like nick has his hand up yeah um
um machete okay just want to get your attention um funny that aaron said that um the number one
thing in a business owner is a hungry business owner right because they they you're not going
to find that you can't as much as I would love to have every business owner be good at sales
most of them suck like they're they're like old plumber let's say it's in the plumbing industry
for septic right we do submit they're probably an old plumber that decided to open their company
they're not trained in sales not always if you find the one that are that are good at plumbing
and business people those ones are really good typically you don't find that so you have to
remember it's kind of like like I guess so aaron aaron is is is currently single just fyi for any
of the ladies out there um at some point aaron's gonna start freaking working the field aaron's
gonna start hunting you know he's gonna start freaking prowling around and uh he's gonna want
to have a list of things even if it's in his head of things that he's looking for and as much as
he'd like to have every single one of those things which he could he may be looking for a long time
and so you kind of have to have this list within your head of like what do you want that business
owner it's your partner what are the things ideally you would want that business owner to have
and then in what order are they most important and to me the most important thing is is a hunger
for leads because if they're hungry for leads then they're gonna do their very very best and
they may not be perfect on the phone they may sound really gravely and scary and they might
have not great customer service but at least they're hungry they're following up they want
that business on the other hand they can be the best talker in the world they can be the best
whatever communicator but if they're not hungry for the leads they're not like francesca said
they're not going to call them they're not going to address them they're not going to um they're
you're going to really really get frustrated so to me the number one thing i look for is a hungry
business owner and how do we know that guys aaron how do we know someone's hungry typically
when they actually are responsive they're responsive but also going back to building the
list is they're already paying yeah we're already paying because if they're already paying they're
either a hungry for more leads or b they're they're allergic to money right and the chance
of it being b is low right so great question awesome well that's it yeah i say this a lot
just because somebody's willing to give you money doesn't mean you should take it
yeah we were talking about that earlier we've all gotten the business owner we know we can close
them we know they give us the money but you just know deep down they're not going to stay with you
for a long time and i will say at the beginning when you start your business sometimes you just
get that deal to get that win get a little money coming in but you'll get to a point where you
realize that person even though i might be able to get them for the next three months it's going
to tie me up during the best time of year i'd rather skip them and wait another two three weeks
and it's hard to make that big boy big girl decision because now you have to cold call again
now you have to go through all the heart the headache and the heartache of doing this again
but if you do that deal that's six months you're going to tie yourself up during the best time and
you might miss out on a better business owner so once you've been in it a while you realize that
not all money is money that you should take and sometimes you can get a deal and you choose not
to get a deal because you know it's not going to last because they as aaron said are not going to
make money if they don't make money they're not going to stay with you no matter how
great the money sounds it's not long-term money it's not big money it's not you know forever money
for sure so with these questions guys if we have time we will do questions at the end we're getting
some great comments but i'll probably kind of just like slowly exit out here and let you guys
handle the topic of the call of how to replace a client beautiful um are you gonna stay on this
call are you hopping off to get to work no i'll stay on because i don't want to like mess up the
hosting with yeah stay on and then i'm gonna have you check the comments i'm not even going
to worry about logging on facebook and have you check the comments and then anything that's
pertinent to what we're talking about then i want you to jump in and ask it so um really quick i
don't know this could take a while this could not take a while but what i want to the the focus of
today's call is i want to talk about getting a new client um replacing your business owner
and so a couple things and i wanted to bring francesca on because she just replaced a business
owner when was this this is just you just replaced this person like last week
yeah so we're going to talk about this this is something that is going to happen so number one
you guys i want to say is that you are going to have to do this and sometimes it's not your fault
right sometimes you're producing great leads nothing's changed and the business owner
they're bad at managing money they something happens and you know what they they they start
cutting they start cutting costs and they're not they're not long-sighted enough to realize
that they're cutting the very thing that's actually growing their business and they're
going to call you and say hey i i just don't want to pay for these leads anymore and that's just a
reality so you are going to have to replace clients it's just part of the game don't feel bad
don't you know crawl in bed it's just going to happen right and i need you guys to remember that
this is the same as physical real estate if you own a fourplex you can't assume that the first
four people you put in there are never going to leave guess what sometimes those people are there
while they gather enough money to go build their own house and sometimes your business owners are
taking your leads long enough that they can go and they can start you know you know really putting
some time and energy and effort into their own website and generating their own leads and guess
what hopefully you you they trust you and you gain enough of their trust that they'll come to you and
you can do that for them but sometimes business owners they they move out right they go on to
other things and sometimes just like tenants maybe their friends are at this other place
and there's a pool there right or there's it's closer to their work and they decide that they're
going to move over there they're going to move their money over there and all you can do just
like if you own the fourplex you could make it the best fourplex in town you could add as many
amenities as possible you could be the the easy to call easy to get a hold of good communication
make sure everything's always working you can make that the best possible situation but sometimes
you are in the wrong location and it's nothing you can do and so you have to remember that even
in physical real estate no matter how good your property is people just move that's it also in
physical real estate guess what you could do everything right and sometimes people are just
crappy people just don't pay their bill people just think that they can sit in your property
and they don't have to pay you right and they're entitled whatever and you have to replace them you
have to evict them and guess what guys sometimes you got to evict your business owners out of these
websites and the good thing is is in this business it's really easy to evict you just take the tracking
number and you switch it to somewhere else and you take the the the quote forms and you push them
somewhere else that's it you're done completely completely done okay so um we want to go through
this really quick and i want to just talk to francesca because she just did this and kind of
go step by step on how to replace it we're going to talk about two different things number one
we're going to talk about how to replace a business how to replace uh a new get a new business owner
for a website that doesn't have a tenant maybe they moved out on their own and now you're stuck
and you don't have any money coming in and that's a little bit more urgent because you're not making
money and then if we have time i want to talk about replacing a business owner when you already
have a business owner finding having a a business owner in tow to come and then drive the other one
out onto the street and do so you know happily put them get them create make the business owner
homeless you know metaphorically and uh and get somebody else in there so francesca let's talk
about when we have a website let's use one of our websites that's currently vacant right like i know
uh is it st george tree service that recently became vacant yeah okay st george tree service
we had a really good client we signed them in 2020 they were with us for over three years and
it was again one of these examples they basically were like hey we're gonna go a different direction
and i think based on what i've seen they probably had their niece or nephew or somebody at a dinner
party was like oh i could do a really good job for you for you're spending a thousand dollars
and they probably are building their own website whatever and they're good people i'm still friends
them on facebook um you know i'm never gonna just burn bridges right but they decided to
to move a different direction so i know we also replaced that tenant with one of our other
tenants that covered this area kind of but they had to drive and it didn't really work out
so we have this property it's vacant st george tree service what you know and i know we've been
focusing on some other properties before this we just uh did a new one and also guys remember
even us we have to do this too so you guys should realize this is just a thing francesca what's the
next step right now we have a vacant property st george tree service what's our very next step
what are you doing and what is our process that anyone could follow yeah so the first thing i do
especially we ended things on a good note is i honestly just ask them and say hey like would
you have someone else that you know would be like kind of ask for a referral and i offer like
a gift card something small um so i do that first if that doesn't work and they don't know anyone
they do know people but they don't want to give you anyone um right um i rebuilt that prospecting
list of business owners especially when it's been a while because you might have new businesses that
came in people are buying ads now whatever it may be i get that refreshed up i also do a due
diligence just in case i want to see like if things change because keep in mind like especially for a
client that you had for three years most likely the ads you really lowered because you started
ranking so i just redo the due diligence as well kind of see where we're at i do a little digging
on the leads that we're getting i honestly don't i feel like it's more pressure when you're starting
a new project than when you're trying to replace one because you do have experience in that project
already you already did half of the work for it and then you know kind of what to expect in terms
of leads for the year most of the time so you have that going going for you and then then i just start
cold calling so that would be those would be the steps in that case so a couple things number one
is that it sounds funny to ask for a referral but it is true and sometimes these business owners
they actually feel bad because they like you they made money with you and for whatever reason they
just want to go a different direction and sometimes it's not even against you so i think it's really
wise to ask because you can actually get referrals and do it in a very strategic way where you don't
come off desperate like maybe say hey sorry sorry to interrupt i just thought about something that
really works if they have a contract let's say it's august now the contract is up in october one
thing that really works is oh i know like you're going a different direction what if you help me
you know find someone else to replace you we can shorten your contract money and get them on before
so they can take over your contract that really really works yeah then they're not on the hook
and it kind of like lets them know hey we are going to stick to this contract just so you know
so i really like that but number one ask and this is going back to so many different things
we talked about guys don't burn bridges don't be a dude like somebody texts you hey they're
going in a different direction you i know like i my immediately first response i want to go burn
their house down right like that's like the first thing i want to do like just burn their house down
you know slash their tires all that stuff that's like my first response right i carry this in my
and after that i'm like okay nick that's you know it's no it's not personal whatever and so
that's that's a great step but this is what i like that francesca said is really important
guys you should be constantly if you have projects even if they're ranking
or maybe they're partially ranking you're still spending money on ads whatever it's always good
to i would say once a year especially as you have client turnover and you're still trying to rank
is i would go and if you're ranked top of the google of google whatever that's fine
right but if you're still in the process bottom page one it's always good to go and do a little
do another due diligence see where things are at see if there's new competition in town see if
there's new people that are running ads go from a to z see that process because you'd be surprised
like there's businesses that like for example artificial grass businesses there's like four
new artificial grass businesses that have popped up in my town since we landed our client and our
client's still with us but if we were to switch over in fact i had somebody reach out to me on
instagram that we could sell those leads do we have we actually have a backup right now francesca
for our artificial grass website that i've told i think i've talked to you about that we just
can't work with because we only work with one company so um do the due diligence right keep
a good relationship ask them for referrals if possible and i was going to say do it in a way
that's not doesn't sound desperate hey mr business owner um you know we've got you know
two or three people that we were talking to when we decided to work with you but before i do that
since i know you and i trust you is there anyone that you would recommend or that you know that we
should talk to before i go talk to those people because i'd always appreciate someone that you
trust because these leads this is my name on this right versus hey do you know anyone i could sell
these two right you sound like the the the the desperate person that's just looking for any and
everything right yeah you you think i could you could hawk these leads for 200 bucks a month
to anybody you know what i'm saying so there's a really fine line of how to do it um and i think
i'm really professional at this because i have an ego and i never want to sound desperate like it's
really hard for me to ask for anything especially for something that makes me look and i put in
that position okay okay so you build a list right you look at the due diligence you build the list
and then does your pitch change talk to us about that does your pitch change is it back to the
exact same thing what are you doing now maybe the website's ranked it's getting a certain amount of
leads you know roughly how many leads it's getting because it's getting you know 20 to 30 leads a
month no ads or very little ads what is your pitch how does it change compared to the first time
talk talk about that for a second yeah i feel i mean i don't know why but i do feel more confident
when i'm pitching something that i already had for a longer time because like you said i know
more of the expectations i know exactly how many leads we have been getting but i still do not
tell them hey this is how much like i still keep you know keep it as a secret because i don't want
them to have high expectations and also like things can change and you never really know so
the only thing that i would say changes is the fact that you go in knowing yourself but i don't
necessarily share them you know with them hey we usually get 20 30 leads you can share like hey
we've been having this project for a very long time we used to work with you don't tell them who
unless it's a referral obviously um so you can tell them like you had yes of course you can take
that and tell them but you don't go you still don't want to promise them 20 30 leads a month
because if for some reason december you're not getting them they call you up smart as much as
you want to i never like to leave with that um unless it's getting like 50 consistently and then
you're like yeah this thing's getting like 20 20 plus right like a number that you get like there's
no way you could go wrong on but other than that i wouldn't even try to you know give them a number
because then they're going to be they're going to be making a decision based on that number so
um my experience call after you lose a tenant and you have leads coming in consistently
it's so much easier to call it's you're you're so much more confident
because you have this project you know what it produces um you've seen it it's been consistent
you know it's not going anywhere and here's the best part is most of the time you don't have to
spend money on ads so you're all the money you're gonna get you're gonna get as mostly profit
right you're not gonna have to worry about ads and all this different stuff and so um okay so when
you do call do you you try to mention that there was somebody before talk about that like how do
you bring it up and i'm just asking you specifically i know the way that i do it um but i'm curious with
you how do you do it do you bring up that you had somebody else buying them do you just say
that you have a website is it the same exact script like tell us about that yeah it depends
like is it coming from a referral then you have to mention it because they probably have already
talked to them and you can kind of leverage that because you can ask the other guy like to give
you like a good review in that terms like they probably talk there you know he then you have that
advantage so it does depend on how did you find them did you just call call them like a new project
or was there a referral that's like the main thing and then yeah it's really based on that
like how did that come through if it's you're just calling them i mean i don't necessarily
tell them like hey we used to have this guy and we lost them so that's why i'm calling you because
you sound desperate okay i agree guys if you have websites right now that are producing leads
especially organic leads you're you're sitting on free money like that should be your number
one priority right now francesco that should be our number one priority right because it's like
this we own some office space in st george and we had you know there was a period of time where
i was in an office kyle was in an office isaac was in an office francesco was in an office i think we
had in one other person that off porter was using an office like we mainly use the offices and then
i started traveling kyle started working from home porter started working on the farm isaac was back
in portland and we were just all remote and i remember just one day and this sounds so silly
that i took me so long but i'm like dude there's literally just money like we're just like there's
free money right and so i started talking to francesco every week i'm like francesco we just
need to rent these offices out because it costs us nothing they're just it's just empty space
that can't bring in money and and that's it she started renting these offices out and i mean
i don't know what did we rent that corner one out for finally um 50 huh the corner one
yeah 650 650 bucks a month times it by 12 that was just sitting there no one is in it
right and and we we in our heads we knew we should rent it out but i mean what is that what is 650
times 12 it's like seven it's like eight thousand bucks something like that right roughly thousand
eight hundred eight eight thousand eight hundred seven seven thousand eight seven thousand eight
hundred dollars that we just were like yeah and all we had to do and francesco took photos she
put it on marketplace lo and behold we're completely booked other than we have one tiny
little office is kyle's little harry potter closet he used to work out of that uh we started letting
him work from home um because he could barely even fit in the door but besides the harry potter
closet we're completely rented out so the fact of the matter if you guys have properties that are
rentable right now that should be your number one focus number one focus and i have a couple of
there's a couple of ideas that i could give you guys guys think outside the box on like yes build
the list right um uh go and do what we did list building the best thing to do is is go and find
people that are paying for google ads but guess what you can also you know what i do every time
i get the mail i freaking i'm collecting these things baby so right now we have a epoxy guy
but guess what as soon as epoxy guy decides to go sideways i got his replacement right here he's
spending money on paper right dude wants leads bad enough he's spending money on this stuff okay
look at that uh that's not a good one i'm not going to do carpet cleaning but i just want to
show you guys an example these guys are spending money on these cards this isn't google ads but
this costs them money these people are hungry for leads or they're stupid either way i want to talk
to you right fun to talk to stupid people sometimes look at this i got a depth cleaning back up as soon
as mr joe go ahead and write this down francesca as soon as mr joe goes sideways duck pros is
getting our leads okay boom evergreen maintenance just i got yeah i don't think that's a good one
just wanted to hold that up what's hold on i got one more for you oh look at this an artificial
grass replacement our third replacement so guys um i actually have a book downstairs
i text my son to bring it up because i don't think he got my message i there's this guy that
i know in town and he has this business called dixie direct direct direct and it's like deals
right his name's tony and he used to live by me and uh he come people they sell these books and
i always buy i don't even use them i buy them just to get ideas i literally last night i was
eating i was eating mexican food and i'm like a hundred years old i'm flipping through this deal
book and i don't give a rat's you know what about deals i do i like free money but i was more
interested in like oh interesting these guys how much because i know how much he charges right he
charges like 5 000 bucks a year so i'm like dude that's like a four or five hundred dollar a month
client right there that's probably not getting any business from this right so just wanted to
point out yes use the go and look for people paying for google ads but don't sleep on this
stuff guys somebody had to pay money to get this to your door that means they want leads this is a
hungry business owner right here okay so eagle creek landscape dude you're in trouble once we
lose our client dude eagle eagle creek they're gonna get freaking either gonna work this or
burn it on their house baby those are two options okay um one more just just a niche idea this is
kind of a side thing and then we're getting questions i never even thought about this niche
this is interesting affordable sheds and garages mobile sheds and garages that's an interesting
niche or maybe it's not even a mobile but maybe it's um just sheds and garages like detached
sheds and garage building that's an interesting one i bet those suckers right there those probably
cost five ten grand right it's a structure and i guarantee they don't cost that much to build
anyway just a niche idea for those of you that think it's saturated and on that note of replacing
a client so obviously talking about prospecting in relation to replacing a client iman says that
facebook and facebook has been an absolute goldmine for finding hungry business owners
but then the caveat problem is finding quality people who actually have money and don't squander
the opportunity but checking marketplace and local business groups has been really good so you can
at least possibly find engagement or interest even if not actively paying a lot of times when
you look in a facebook group and it's like the recommendations on concrete and then people will
tag yeah talk to mark mark doesn't even have a business but it's like he's the number one
recommended person it's a good lead but you have to remember that that person might be getting a
lot of inbound business so they might not be hungry but i remember i had my my very first towing client
before i sold my website to i actually sold it to shiv i don't know if you guys knew this
but shiv's actually the one that bought my freaking dumpy websites shit i freaking just
dumped that on ship i'm kidding he still makes like 600 bucks a month for the last three years
he actually won but i couldn't find a client man i went through everybody dude and towing is not
a fun one francesca just replaced our towing client and it's a hard one because towing people
are generally not that intelligent it's hard it's hard it's hard to even get motivated to talk to
these people because they're just they're just not smart like mostly right that sounds rude
they're just not i went to lunch with one dude dude's belly's hanging out freaking just i mean
and i mean that like hanging out standing like he did doesn't care about life in the whole time
it was just the whole conversation was loud and he didn't get it right and i only say that because
they're just sloppy like wear a t-shirt that fits dude taking this guy to lunch and his t-shirt
doesn't even fit if that's not indicative of the fact he's not going to answer the phone nothing
is guys you're here we're talking to a business owner make sure their t-shirt fits that's like
number one okay okay so um where was i going with this i'm like i'm i'm i'm turning into
west here i'm clear over here and then i'm apologizing oh where was i at um long story
short guys is you can think outside the box yeah iman said facebook is a good place to get ideas
but remember the number one thing with replacing someone is a hungry business owner i'll take that
over over the good sales guy over the polished person because if they're hungry you they're
trained they're usually teachable they're coachable they're whatever so
just keep dude i have a collection of this stuff okay let's go through a couple questions really
quick awesome yeah and by the way actually guys what we're gonna do is this is something and nick
we actually haven't talked about this but what we'll start to do is after each live we're
transitioning things over to um a better way to handle support because obviously we've been doing
dms for the longest time and honestly guys it gets a little some it's easy to miss messages
because obviously facebook messenger is not meant for like crm right like it's just meant for like
homies interacting but what we're obviously we've announced this a while back with transitioning
things something called fresh desk it's just going to be a better support ticket system
but not only just handling messages the reason i bring that up is after each live what we're
going to start to do is actually create like a little like a cheat sheet for each of these lives
so obviously we were talking about in this one how to replace a client francesca just listed off
like five bullet points or five steps and so what we're gonna do is we're gonna put that in
like a nice little article or a little document on fresh desk put under frequently asked questions
such as how to replace a client that way you guys can have that and i think one thing we're talking
about too is taking these lives putting them into kajabi and title you know titling them and putting
the attached digital resource with it so we're gonna try and get you guys you know instead of
having to watch the whole live again give me a look at the cheat sheet and go oh yeah here was
the bullet points whatever so yeah you guys can start expecting that guys you should be in you
should have kajabi the training bookmarked and you should be in it every day because they're we're
literally adding stuff every day like at least a couple times a week so anyway see if there's
any other questions yeah no for sure so um Mahmood said he'll take uh the harry powder closet needs
some peace and quiet love it bro come out bro every time Mahmood comes out good things happen
we we do random cold calls on the spot um let's see brad hardy said i'm in portable building niche
5k minimum i think relating to the shed idea there we go there's another niche i've never even thought
about that niche francesca can we do some due diligence on saint george utah today please today
yeah let's go ahead and do that okay this yeah for sure luke hill said i'm curious if you guys
can do a training on best way to price deals there's an immediate live nick or at least
youtube video that i remember what you kind of talked about when you went through the tool
so i can yeah will you share that and come back maybe what you can do is after we get off you can
go find it and then post it as a reply that's a really good training because there it's there's
a very calculated formula for how to price deals like we don't just guess it's literally based on
a formula so post that but yeah we could always do that again i don't think there's much that we
could say on top of what we already said because nothing's changed but we do have a very specific
formula on how to price deals oh yeah for sure it gives you a whole lot of confidence because
it's just math in the end it removes the emotion from sales and that's what we say in the training
too is like this is for the business owner to make it make sense but it's more for you to go
in there confidently going hey if i can even get half of what i'm thinking i can double your money
as long as you answer the freaking phone and do a decent job and you can go in there asking for a
retainer of two thousand bucks with confidence not just shaking in your boots freaking you know
with that tight t-shirt with mr towing keep going yeah for sure this is an earlier question about
the tool iman said did you build the tool are you just promoting it or kind of like just getting
so we built it we've been working on this anytime you build tools they tell you it's going to take
a certain amount of time you always are like yeah we're going to expect the worst case and it's
always like double that because so i have been it's been over a year for just so you know it's
been over one year so those of you that are think i've just been avoiding it's been a year and i
finally was like dude i'm tired of like using semrush i'm literally spending 99 bucks a month
for semrush for for the search feature and i was like annoyed so um right now i'm over
50 000 into this thing in a year so this isn't just some you know i'm not promoting you guys
know this i don't sell we haven't we don't try to sell you guys stuff right the only reason we even
talk about this is because i'm tired of using tools i don't trust and because i'm spending 99
bucks on what so yeah we built this thing and it's it's legit so and i'm we're going to talk
more about that um coming up and uh you know get into that but yeah keep going for sure we got some
good questions so matthew says is it viable to try and snatch a few leads from fb groups to use also
to close deals uh before ads take off i remember you did talk about this it's pretty hit or miss
but can work what are your thoughts on it did you know what he's asking you cut out the first half
is it viable to take going to facebook groups grab a few free leads and use those to go hook
a deal and get the process going while you're waiting for ads
can you repeat it sorry no you're you're good so like and uh the like facebook groups people ask
for recommendations like hey who has a local concrete guy right can we use those leads those
interested people as a form of free leads on our end to give to business owners while we're
waiting for ads to take off or even to supplement them to get the deal i think so yeah nick you did
a live on this or youtube video i think like last year the only thing i i like to use facebook group
leads to pick up the slack i don't like to use them to start a deal usually sometimes i'll use
them to hook a deal to test the market i don't love once i know the market's good to use them
because then if my ads don't kick in it's like i don't have a predictable way to continually just
scrape leads but if i'm running ads and my ads slow down it's a great way to go get like some
sweat equity deals and go get some leads that way um so my opinion is hook them use those leads to
get interest to gauge interest to call around to get somebody on the hook if you need to if you
want to do that without setting up ads but i like to have my my leads coming in from ads and then
use those as a supplement rather than my main thing because i don't i can't predict when people
are going to ask for recommendations right um so that's just my two cents but leads are leads guys
it's about strategy versus tactic the strategy is giving free leads in advance the tactic that
we're using is is google ads but guess what if you guys can if somebody in this group can come up
with a predictable um you know repeatable way to glean and and harvest leads out of facebook groups
forever and we don't have to run ads go ahead and and hit me up on dms and we'll go ahead and
implement that and stop running ads but ads is just the most predictable thing let me answer one more
question and then what i want to do erin is i want you guys to finish out the questions i got to go
take my kids to school really quick but i want you guys to finish these questions let me answer one
more yeah i think that was actually all the questions the only thing i just want to actually
give a shout out for is daniel said he has got a lot of newbie technical questions because he just
um joined but he was hoping to have a little chitchat with someone to just kind of get on the
right path so obviously daniel watch the training that's going to be like the 80 90 95 percent of
all you need to know but actually jason already messaged he's going to hop on and chat with him
so thank you jason the man everyone jason's been awesome i've probably been seeing him in the free
group lately he's been killing it um guys wrapping this call up you're going to see it inside a
kajabi you're going to see a digital resource going out um that kind of outlines this but i
think the biggest takeaway for me if you have sites that are producing leads you guys have office
space that's waiting to be rented out that costs you nothing to get a a tenant and you're you're
you're flushing money down the toilet like you're literally wiping your behind with money and
flushing it down the toilet it's just free money
francesca let's go get let's go get saint george tree service locked down let's go i'm going to
send you a picture of this we're going to look at this as well but before this the priority should
be your your websites that already have leads coming in because it's done you just need to
find a tenant boom you turn it on it's done it's free money so erin thank you for jumping on
francesca thank you for jumping on guys let's go make some freaking money and i will see you guys
later in the week going live or next tuesday thanks guys all right take care guys